c'est une relaxation qui devant tout un
conventionnement
la lumière
l'installation
le logo choisi en quelques minutes
apprendre à se relaxer à se déstresser
des petits exercices pratiques présentés
par marie thérèse ross c'est la
présidente du réseau qu'ahmad pour le
maintien à domicile
elle est surtout kinésithérapeutes et
gérontologue tout est parti d'un constat
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui te
rappelle être appris très jeune si on
apprenait déjà aux personnes à respirer
il ya deux personnes sur trois qui
respire mal grandi aux personnes
respirent et enlève les épaules les
pouvant ils sont pas dans les écoles
d'envoyer sont des choses très basiques
on croit savoir les concepts pour savoir
comment faire il suffit d'appliquer une
méthode toute simple basée sur la
respiration profonde tout d'abord
respirer doit être naturelle et ne pas
forcer ses mouvements première leçon on
inspire on appuie sur ses côtes pour
sentir l'air dans son corps et on
souffle
tel un accordéon deuxième leçon on
inspire lentement toujours par le nez on
gonfle ont le ventre et on souffle par
la bouche en lui trouvant un peu il faut
que le mouvement soit harmonieux comme
créer un va-et-vient d'air qui va
apaiser des battements du coeur cette
méthode appelée respiration profonde ou
respiration par le ventre peut aussi
aider à l'endormissement
enfin troisième leçon on inspire
doucement jusqu'au maximum on sert le
ventre en bloquant la respiration
pendant 10 secondes l'air va nettoyer
l'intérieur du corps et on expire en
rejetant le maximum d'air le principe
souffler le double de ce que l'on
inspire
inspiré très bien souffler parce que
c'est vraiment efficace c'est vrai
qu'avec le travail je pense que
justement ça va permettre d'évacuer les
grosses tensions qui lia je suis sûre
même que ça doit apporter beaucoup quand
on a des problèmes de sommeil c'est la
simplicité je trouve bien parce que on
peut refaire facilement
fatigue quand même
prenant de l'âge je pense que c'est une
bonne chose pour faire un kill temps de
repos dans la journée des exercices dit
alain minutes que l'on peut faire chez
soi ou sur son lieu de travail il ne
crée pas d'endormissement mais offre une
pause salutaire dans des journées
souvent très chargé